you have to
[Music]
tim mcgraw is opening up about that
surprise cameo from tom hanks in the
yellowstone prequel 1883. the oscar
winner appeared in a civil war flashback
playing a general named george meade tim
looked back on working with his good
friend tom during an interview with big
machine label group it was pretty
spectacular for tom hanks to show up and
do this scene we've been friends for
such a long time we're family friends
forever kids are friends faith and
reader are best friends and so to ask
him to do this singing and he says sure
i'll be there tell me when it was just
so incredible
the moving battleground scene stirred up
a lot of emotions for tim who recalled
how he fell apart during filming no
matter how good a friend you are and how
well you know someone when you're
sitting there in a scene that's that
emotional and you see tom hanks walk up
in a union uniform
and look at you and say captain
and then he sit beside me and he puts
his hand on my shoulder he goes i know i
just fell apart if you haven't seen the
show yet it stars tim and his wife faith
hill co-starring as james and margaret
dutton heading west to the great plains
with their two young children tim also
opened up about putting himself in real
danger shooting the show's wagon scenes
the third biggest cause of death were
these wagon trains it was river crossing
and drowning it was just so treacherous
and so dangerous i mean you never knew
where the holes were in the river you
never knew how deep it was we spent
three days doing it just about every
scene i shot with my horse he was trying
to throw me in the middle of the river